so no come on
nah just ten minutes no for all the RAM
we knew thrown at me for dr. who I think
you owe me this
alright but after ten minutes I get to
hit you so it bringing back some of the
cast from the original Star Wars Oh Lord
spare us look I know I don't want to see
Han old and grumpy either I got my fill
of that with Indiana Jones but it's
happening so let's think of the
possibility what do you mean the
possibility of seeing your hero's fat
and unappealing on screen there's
potential here Luke instructing young
Jedi it could be awesome
all right who would you bring back well
I I don't think I have the strength for
this I know you've lost your faith but
he used to care about these characters
set your cynicism aside for a second and
think of the possibilities when dou
Calrissian wedge antilles Admiral Ackbar
Lando's big-lipped copilot from Jedi Yin
um okay the fact that you knew that off
the top of your head is disturbing well
look I'm not saying he's a great
character but it would prove a point
which is look I didn't just lose faith
in that franchise Lucas lost his faith
in the audience that character spoken on
human language no subtitles we didn't
miss a beat the prequels that was all
gone every single alien speaks English
even when they're only talking amongst
themselves the few who didn't were
always subtitled look just show me that
Disney and JJ Abrams have the faith in
the audience to bring back a character
like ninny new posits and maybe maybe
I'll have a little hope okay what about
Chewie
they blew they're pointless chewy cameo
in episode 3 Chuy's out mini I knew you
were gonna take this seriously and I
knew you were gonna wait for Cathy to
leave for New Zealand before you even
dared talking thoose e a Stickley about
Star Wars how gone
look you're cynical but she's just evil